si desde fuera de Estados Unidos vemos
los diferentes procesos que enfrenta
Trump este podría no parecer tan grave
pero entonces por qué levanta tanto
revuelo y Qué posibilidades reales hay
de que Trump se ha imputado
muy buenas noches Valentina Así es este
no es uno de los crímenes más grandes
que se le imputan o por los que están
habiendo investigaciones sin embargo es
el primero que Está avanzando y vieron
hoy presentaciones de datos Y que pronto
podemos Escuchar alguna resolución del
Jurado por eso es el primero que se está
discutiendo pero tiene razón no es el
más grave Este es un ejemplo más en el
que Trump usa sus seguidores para tratar
de de salirse con la suya y de tener lo
que él dice es un apoyo de su movimiento
hacia su persona Bueno y qué supondría
para Trump esa imputación y también para
la democracia en Estados Unidos
la democracia no se ve afectada Está
siguiendo las órdenes de la corte y lo
que los tribunales digan él ya ha
comentado que aunque se ha imputado de
estos cargos él seguiría corriendo las
elecciones ese sería este siendo un
candidato y por ser un crimen no
violento no es probable que vaya a la
cárcel Así que es una manera que se está
usando Trump de llamar a sus seguidores
para mostrar su apoyo y un poquito para
amenazar a en este caso al al a la gente
Nueva York de que no lo de que no
intente ponerlo este bajo
bajos celda todavía bueno Y aunque
saliera absuelto puede que este caso
afecte su carrera frente a ron de santis
que es un hombre muy conservador en las
primarias del partido republicano
curiosamente lo ha usado muy
inteligentemente Trump para ver quién
está apoyándolo y quién no la base del
partido republicano sigue siendo muy
fiel a Trump y se le estaba presionando
mucho para que de santis hablara en
contra de estos cargos que vienen y ha
conseguido esto Trump Y entonces de
santis lleva una declaración donde dice
que esto es algo puramente político sin
embargo no hay mucha evidencia en muchos
de los casos contra Trump de que sean
roto vayas varias leyes Por lo cual es
un proceso serio